[Music]
it may sound strange but as a liberal I
really do believe in American
exceptionalism due to our democratic
ideals and personal freedoms America is
a unique and special country in the
world I really do believe that you may
remember back in 2009 when President
Obama said he didn't really believe in
American exceptionalism saying quote I
believe in American exceptionalism just
as I suspect that the Brits believe in
British exceptionalism and the Greeks
believe in Greek exceptionalism in and
of itself there's nothing wrong with
Obama's general idea here in which each
individual country is filled with proud
people who believe that their country is
unique and special in the world actually
if this idea fuels people to build a
better society that they can be
genuinely proud of then fantastic of
course by the same token this
nationalism could also push otherwise
good people to believe that they should
have inordinate sway over the world or
influence other nations because they're
morally superior over the eight years of
Obama's presidency he walked back this
statement and did actually say that
America's exceptionalism was unique for
me there's an additional reason for
American exceptionalism which goes
beyond just our democratic ideals and
our personal freedoms obviously we are
the only country in the world to share
in those ideas it's also the additional
peace that America is a country of
immigrants a country of people from all
over the world who came here to make a
better life for themselves
we are a nation built by people whose
ancestors often came here with nothing
and who worked hard to build a better
country in life for their children and
their children's children
while we certainly aren't the only
country to welcome immigrants or to
build a solid middle-class there's no
other nation on earth that more people
from more countries have come to live
and prosper because of the pursuit of
happiness this doesn't mean that
everyone can come here and we can have
open borders but it does mean that if
you come here legally you'll be given
the same chance as a natural-born
citizen even today as we live in a
politically fractured society and many
people will tell you that things have
never been worse
the
is that things have actually never been
better now of course I don't mean that
for every specific person or every
specific job or every specific industry
times change and so do people and
economies but as a whole America has
done an incredible job of welcoming so
many diverse people having us all share
in the American dream while at the same
time all being able to keep traditions
and practices from our unique cultures
as our economy changes over the next few
years we the people have a massive job
of changing along with it in an age
where supermarkets will be automated and
driverless cars will replace truck
drivers it will be more important than
ever for us to change along with the
technology the world doesn't stop for
anyone or owe you anything you have to
adapt to a changing world and in these
moments of change that's usually where
America has been at it's at its best our
system built on the idea that it's your
job to pursue your happiness is the
reason that more people still want to
come to America right now than any other
country on earth I always find it ironic
that so many people who rant and rave
about how evil America's are the same
people who demand that we let anyone in
here why would anyone want to come to
such an evil unfair and oppressive
society of course this is nonsense and
these people know it there's a reason
that people don't leave America in
droves even the celebrities who said
they would leave if Trump was elected
have somehow managed to stay here for
the record I'm pretty sure that Canada
is happy that they don't have to take in
most of those people I mentioned all
this because for all the goodness here
in America we obviously still have some
work to do every society has work to do
which is why people peddling utopia are
always frauds and Liars in America
though almost every generation has
fought to expand rights to other people
not to limit them that's how we got
women the right to vote that's how we
freed the slaves and that's how gay
people were allowed to marry and that's
how whatever will come next will arrive
as for that work that we have to do I
think a lot of it has to do with how we
can come together instead of just
ripping each other apart
I'm a firm believer that most of us want
the same things in life we want to work
a decent job
eat some good food have some sex and go
on vacation now and again most of us
aren't racist homophobe secretly
plotting against each other and trying
to push our way of life on everyone else
this is somewhere which no matter where
your political leanings are we can all
come together yes some of us are from
big cities some of us are from small
towns some of us have had ancestors who
arrived on the Mayflower and some of us
just arrived yesterday but the only way
this all works is if we all bend to fit
the American ideals of freedom and of
Liberty
not if we demand that the system bend to
us my guest this week is comedian Trey
Crowder Trey is known as the liberal
redneck apparently they do exist
his comedy is a blend of showing liberal
elites that rednecks aren't all
backwards Hicks and showing rednecks
that liberals aren't all evil socialists
it's almost as if we should judge people
as individuals not as groups where have
I heard that before you know the middle
of this country for a long time has been
the brunt of jokes and the easy way to
make fun of anyone who thinks
differently than the people in New York
or Los Angeles as someone who has only
lived in New York or Los Angeles
I've never subscribed to this way of
thinking and I've tried not to mock
people just because they talk
differently or haven't evolved on some
social views the second that I have
whether you're democrat or republican
straight or gay black or white Native
American or new immigrant this country
belongs to all of us and it needs all of
us to continue to make it better that's
the thing with exceptionalism it takes
an awful lot of work to keep up
[Music]
you